with the terror threat now in many
places
keeping thousands of troops grounded and
concentrated in just one country
at a cost of billions each year makes
little sense to me
and to our leaders we cannot continue
the cycle
of extending or expanding our military
presence in afghanistan
hoping to create ideal conditions for
the withdrawal
and expecting a different result i'm now
the fourth
united states president to preside over
american troop presence in afghanistan
two republicans two democrats i will not
pass this responsibility onto a fifth
after consulting closely with our allies
and partners
with our military leaders and
intelligence personnel with our
diplomats
and our development experts with the
congress and the vice president
as well as with mr ghani and many others
around the world
i've concluded that it's time to end
america's longest war
it's time for american troops to come
home
yeah so when will it be
the right moment to leave one more year
two more years ten more years
10 20 30 billion dollars more and above
the trillion we've already spent
not now that's how we got here
in this moment there's a significant
downside risk to saying beyond may 1st
without a clear timetable for departure
if we instead pursue the approach where
america
u.s exit is tied to conditions on the
ground
we have to have clear answers to the
following questions
just what conditions require to be
required to allow us
to depart by what means
and how long would it take to achieve
them if they could be achieved at all
and at what additional cost in life and
treasure
i've not heard any good answers to these
questions
and if you can't answer them in my view
we
should not stay we already have service
members doing their duty in afghanistan
today
whose parents served in the same war
we have service members who are not yet
born
when our nation was attacked in 9 11.
war in afghanistan was never meant to be
a multi-generational undertaking
we were attacked we went to war with
clear goals
we achieve those objectives bin laden is
dead
and al qaeda is degraded in iraq in
afghanistan
and it's time to end the forever war